Welcome to English in a Minute,...
...where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
There are times when something occurs and you might say,...
..."This left a bad taste in my mouth."
What does this phrase mean?
A bad taste in my mouth.
Hey, how was your vacation?
It was great.
But we had all of the money stolen from our hotel room.
Oh, I'm sorry to hear that.
I know, the whole thing left a really bad taste in my mouth.
If something leaves you with a bad taste in your mouth,...
...you feel there is something wrong about the situation.
It gives you an unpleasant feeling or memory.
Of course, you also can eat something that literally leaves a bad taste in your mouth.
Either way, if something leaves a bad taste in your mouth, it isn't good.
And that's English in a Minute.